Oh mr. deville hi what are you doing
here working on Labor Day if you could
believe it we've been holed up in this
office all day there's an intruder in
the building and the still at large
come with me I don't think I've ever
been down here before this is our floor
it's sort of the nerve center of the
company
[Music]
it's very sad
I have to say this little Hut is
starting to feel downright spooky
we're like the Hardy Boys Oh No
scooby-doo OH your Scooby you'll shaggy
and I'm Bella she was the smart one well
looks like the cafeteria is empty you
know what they used to do in scooby-doo
they get distracted and make these
really big sandwiches
[Music]
so you two were the only ones here all
day then you work the whole time yeah I
guess you could say work is our passion
impressive
I'm a bit of a procrastinator myself if
I don't want to do something I just
started goofing off I can't picture that
I hate it when something gets stuck in
my teeth
ruins my whole day it always happens to
me with popcorn oh yeah I went to the
movies last night and saw the new
oscar-nominated animated shorts with my
friend popcorn David corn
anyway the shorts were the shorts really
interesting shorts
there's Davis a really solid dude you
know what I'm always tempted to do what
I need alone what snoop around in other
people's offices would that be fun
[Music]